foreign
there's an unfortunate reality in the
Venture world that
really became very crystal clear to me
through a conversation with Howard marks
actually but it's structurally set up
you know people talk about boom busting
Cycles but this is set up more like a
Sawtooth so risk on happens very slowly
almost like the
roller coaster
going up but when it crashes and if it's
interesting too I explain or do my best
job of explaining why it's structured
this way when it crashes it happens all
at once so it's more like a Sawtooth
like than a sine wave and it just
crashes and it's painful
and that just happened and it happens it
looks like it happens every seven to
fifteen years you know and I thought
this was going to happen six years ago I
even wrote some things I was way early
it took six more years and it got
ridiculously crazy but it took so long
from 09 which was the last kind of and
09 wasn't as hard to reset as 01 but
from 09 to 2013 because so many
entrepreneurs are young you know you had
people grow up that had never seen a
reset and yeah risk on is a lot like the
boiled frog like you don't know what's
happening would you mind just quickly
defining risk on for people listening
what do you mean by that
so the community
as a whole takes on more risk gradually
without realizing they're doing it and
their mental models and their Frameworks
adjust daily to what's happening and so
their
thought about how the world works is
really a window of five years or maybe
three years not 30 years yep because for
many of them they don't have the 30-year
perspective
and when the going gets good greed takes
over and you weigh the data points that
feel good to you and are going to make
you a lot of confirmation by yourself
like crazy and so then you've shortened
your window to the last 12 months you
know this is how the world works and
because things got so sloppy with
interest rates being near zero
speculation so high money everywhere we
taught a lot of people not only
valuation things that will never be true
again but like
growth at all costs spend as much money
as you can you can raise money every
nine months if you want to because you
could you know the failure rate of
companies in the five years prior to
this reset is probably like the super
low probably the lowest it's ever been
failure rate of startups just because it
was so easy to raise money and so you
develop minimum models and then the
world shifts dramatically 180 degrees
whatever you want to say like it
couldn't be more dramatic how fast it
shifted and you know even today
entrepreneurs will say well I just need
to hold on until things get back to
normal and yeah I'm not the only one
there's other things this is normal dude
like that was a fantasy you were in and
you need to forget it fast but you can't
and there's another painful thing that I
don't even jest about because it creates
real problems and it's actually quite
unfortunate but Founders whatever that
Peak valuation is they ran the math
where they took their ownership they
moved multiplied it by that number and
they thought about their net worth that
way and that can just be super
destructive like once it's no longer
true you mean psychologically
technologically yeah I think it's super
difficult to come to terms with once
you've been through that
what do you mean by valuation multiples
are always a hack proxy
so this gets into some of the earlier
stuff we talked about just about how
deep you go on investing history and
understanding investors but if there is
a scale of financial sophistication
between one and ten and you would say a
really smart person in New York is a
eight and a half the average Silicon
Valley person on financial literacy is a
two lately and it's funny because they
make fun of Wall Street but it's just
out of ignorance they don't yeah know
anything and so most of them think about
valuation by a price to revenue multiple
which couldn't be a cruder
tool and at one point I wrote a
blog post called the keys to the 10x
Revenue club and I took all the public
tech stocks and laid them into end based
on price to revenue and one of them was
at 20 and one of them was at point one
and it was just a big curve so there's
no line there there's no reason to
believe that that price to revenue is
how you should value anything but just
because it's easy and these companies
are young and immature it's hard to do a
DCF it's hard to do something more
sophisticated it's the common language
of the group but things changed
overnight and so someone was was
pointing out I think on Twitter that and
they use price to gross margin instead
of price for Revenue still twilio went
from 70 times gross margin to three
it's like in a very short window I mean
talk about valuation reset that is just
radical and so
that
shakes the industry yeah and no one's
going to feel sorry for Silicon Valley
and I'm not trying to elicit empathy but
just in terms of understanding what
happens it is so
foundational the change is so radical
that the best thing you can possibly
happen is if you can adjust your mental
models fast and get on with the new
world but it's very hard for people to
do it I write that this kind of stuff in
part to help the industry and I'm you
know I'm super grateful Sequoia in 09
put out there's a famous deck they put
out so long good times or something like
that and these things help people adjust
faster yeah having mental models having
structure having smart people tell them
it's okay it gets them there faster